Shigure Aki's evolution throughout my
here academia has been pretty damn
amazing both as a character and in terms
of his raw power when we were first
introduced to this character all might
very appropriately described him as a
man-child but time and time again he's
learned from his mistakes made the right
allies and got in the upper hand against
his enemies on more than one occasion
for this video I'll be explaining his
new quark upgrades which he received
after undergoing a procedure at the
hands of dr. groggy if you're new to
this channel or just having subject then
be sure to click that button for more
videos like this also there will be
monumental manga spoilers so if you only
watch the anime and don't want to know
then like I always say you can wait two
or three years for this to be animated
but yeah I consider this your warning we
were introduced to sugar our keys decay
quoi quite early on in this series and
as it was then he could disintegrate
anything or anyone that he touched when
he made contact with all five fingers
this was used to injure aizawa's elbow
and to nearly kill floppy if not for an
intervention over time we see decay used
to disintegrate random things like this
photo of Deku or stain sword or this
random guy from the Shi his eye Chi
however it wasn't until my villain
academia that this power began to
fundamentally improve Ezra destro said
in the right circumstances quartz can
evolve on the spot and in Shigure Aki's
case he had three of his fingers
destroyed but was able to start
disintegrating with just two remaining
fingers on his hand this is what
eventually led to the climax of the arc
where he basically wiped out entire
neighbourhoods and created a meteor
sized hole in Dhaka City now you'd think
that would be enough power but after
undergoing a gross operation shigaraki
now has a set of abilities currently
unrivaled by any other character in the
show the only person who could
hypothetically compare to him is Deku
but currently he's only at about 30% of
one for all comfortably and he's we've
only ever seen him use one of the six
additional quirks he's meant to get so
if they were to fight right now
Deku would be as dead as he was in this
panel the first big upgrade that I want
to mention is that sugar aki now has the
power of the original alpha 1 quark
which just further solidifies his final
boss status even more all-4-one acts
like a hub for the tons of other quirks
stood inside it and
segaki some instinctive knowledge of how
each power works in addition to that he
also has the ability to steal other
people's quarks from them potentially
including one for all because it's been
implied on many occasions now in the
manga that he is somehow capable of
doing that and if he chooses to he can
also pass on quarks that he doesn't want
anymore to people like Dobby mr. corpus
whoever he wants really he can pass on
any quark he feels like I want to see
garganta macchia with washes quark and
his hero costume ASAP before we get into
the other new quirks he has though let's
first talk about the ridiculous
upgrade to his basic decay ability there
are three noticeable things that seem to
have changed with some being more
important than others so I'm gonna start
with the most minor one the smallest
alteration we have is a visual change as
to how the decay spreads used to create
these regular cracks in the ground
basically exactly what you would expect
from a quark called decay but since the
operation if you notice the decay
passing through the ground it almost
looks mechanical in the way it's
designed and the lines are drawn in a
way that tells you that this is not a
natural thing it's also quite comparable
to offer ones fingers in this moment
this brings us to the biggest upgrade
which is that decay now acts almost like
a virus and I'll explain what I mean up
until this point in order to decay
something Shigure aki has to maintain
contact this was even the case after his
quark evolution in my villain academia
but in Chapter 275 of the manga we saw
that a piece of stray ruble that is
clearly no longer connected to sugar aki
in any way it falls on top of a pro-hero
and disintegrates him on the spot
Shigure aki is not in contact with this
piece of rock it is an independent
object but it still carried the effects
of his decay quark regardless almost
like it's been infected by a virus this
shows us that decay can now be carried
through inanimate objects even after
sugar aki himself has been removed from
the equation finally the last change to
this quark was explicitly mentioned by
shigaraki himself and that is that he
can now control when he disintegrates
things with the exception of his own
body
Shigure aki does not touch anything with
all five fingers because he can't
actually control what he decays if we
look at this panel here he picks up his
father's hand with four fingers he
explicitly avoids making contact with
the
fifth finger and again he did so when he
encountered Deku as he was holding that
fifth finger you know above deck whose
neck because he didn't want to
disintegrate him at that moment he also
did this when he was holding a pair of
binoculars and this clearly shows that
he can't control the decay because if he
did then he would just touch them with
all five fingers and just control
whether or not he wants to decay them
luckily for him though he can now fully
control it after this operation so he
can touch you with all five fingers and
if he wants to he can decay or he won't
decay it's up to him moving on within
alpha one one of the new quirks that
Shiki has is called search which reveals
the location and weaknesses of anyone
that the user has seen before
this quote is quite interesting because
it came preloaded with all the
information that the previous user had
built up so because ragdoll had this
power and then used it on Deku and back
ago and the other students shigaraki is
now capable of hunting them down and
knowing exactly where they are at all
times which is absolutely terrifying I
will say that the range of this quirk
hasn't been specified yet so I don't
know if he'd be able to find Deku he was
like halfway across the world but from
what we've seen so far it is obviously
capable of being used from a very far
distance at least the length of a city I
would imagine because this quirk was
stolen so recently what I think happened
is that after all one took ragdolls
quark that moment is when he then gave
up his original offer one quark and
replaced it with the duplicate version
that he then used to fight all mine if
I'm right that means that shigaraki has
access to every single quark we sawed
off one use during the battle against
all might at a minimum he I mean he
obviously has many more quirks beyond
that as well this is further supported
by the fact that we saw sugar aku used
the air cannon quark against endeavor
which is another one that awful one has
showed off previously air cannon emits a
powerful shockwave of air that by itself
was capable of sending endeavour flying
straight through a rock this same quark
was used against all might to do some
damage so air cannon is a pretty
powerful one that [ __ ] rocky now has at
his disposal in the manga we see sugar
Aki combined air cannon with another
quirk called radio waves and by
combining these two abilities at once he
was able to fry the communication system
that the heroes were using which was a
pure stroke of genius on top of that
we've seen that Shaggy now has the super
regeneration quark which is
quark normally seen by the black no
mousse this right here is what makes
shaggy the strongest villain that the
universe of my academia has ever seen
even the original f1 himself never had a
regeneration ability which is why he
looks the way he does because all might
beat him so badly this regeneration
quirk meant that shaggy was completely
unfazed by being engulfed by flames and
he continued to move around as if
nothing had happened to be able to
nullify the actions of the number one
hero like this yeah it's pretty damn
powerful another quirk that he almost
definitely has is spring-like limbs
which is possibly what enabled him to
jump super high and super fast in the
recent chapters knowing what we know now
I'd say it might be a combination of
spring-like limbs plus the multiple
strengthen heartening quirks that wolf
one definitely had but you got to admit
that when Shigure Aki's jumping at this
speed and at this power
I mean spring-like limbs wouldn't make a
lot of sense speaking of all for one
this guy loved to use the forced quark
activation quark which not only
activates a person's power but also can
be used to throw enemies around or just
straight-up stab them we haven't seen
shigaraki use this one yet but like I
said if he has the search quark which
was stolen most recently then he'd also
have the quirks that were stolen before
this which include force quark
activation back in the day
all-4-one also had this black lightning
quirk which he used to kill Nana shamora
and nuke an entire city in the process
it would obviously be super ironic if
Shigure Aki was to harness the very
quirk that killed his own grandmother
and for that reason I have no doubt that
all one would have definitely left it
for sugar aki to use before we get into
a cool bit of trivia about wolf one
let's touch on the remaining abilities
that sugar aki likely has it goes
without saying that there's many more we
have no idea about with radiowaves be an
example of that as we had never seen
that quote before other powers that
you'll likely have include the black
warping quirk the life force quirk that
allows you to live doubly as long and
that was a power held by both Fujiko and
f1
so sugar aki has it that would be the
third copy of this same quark
additionally a popular theory going
around is that he'll have the
overclocked quark which for those of you
who don't read vigilantes overclock
allows a person to move so fast that
their surroundings look like they've
been frozen in place but the
catches that it can't be used for more
than a few real-life seconds at a time
I'm not actually sure if oh one himself
still had this quirk in the present day
but much like super generous I mean dr.
huge Rico is clearly added additional
quirks to Shigure aki that all-4-one
himself didn't have and so for that
reason I think yeah it is possible that
sugar aki does have overclock but with
that said those were all the quotes that
sugar ah he definitely has after his
operation and also a few them that I'm
just speculating about getting into the
trivia that I mentioned earlier if you
look at sugar Rocky's hand in this panel
you'll see that in the center of his
hand is a massive hole this hole in your
hand is a side-effect of the OL funk
work as we saw during a flashback to all
for one's young days he also had this
same hole in his hand
we then see these holes in his hand
again during the battle at Camino which
is obviously over a hundred years later
so this might explain why people win the
all foreign power can only skill quirks
by using their hands but sadly the anime
has not done this justice at all as all
for one during the battle in the anime
he has no holes in his hand and neither
did 9 either for the manga was a cool
little piece of trivia just before we
end the video though I did a discussion
with one of my fellow youtubers the
other day and we were talking about the
other new quirks of Shigure aki might
have so if that interests you then the
links should be on the screen or in the
description either way don't forget to
sub to the channel as we are on the road
to 100k pizza